[Música]
Hola y bienvenidos a Europa hoy el
programa de actualidad Europea de France
24 en español yo soy Esther Herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo en Bruselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy analizamos la situación de la
crisis climática y las medidas tomadas
en la Unión Europea ahora que ya se ha
dado punto y final a la competición
antes de pasar al debate hacemos un
pequeño repaso a las políticas llevadas
a cabo en la Unión Europea y Cuál es la
situación en el planeta
el tiempo de descuento ante la crisis
climática ya llegó Este es el mensaje de
la ONU durante la conferencia del clima
de este año celebrada en Egipto los
datos hablan por sí solos el informe
provisional sobre el estado del clima
mundial alerta que la tierra se ha
calentado más de 1,1 grados Celsius
desde finales del siglo 19 y
aproximadamente la mitad de ese aumento
se produjo en los últimos 30 años de
mantenerse esta tendencia 2022 era el
año más cálido de la historia
las temperaturas máximas y los fenómenos
adversos se están convirtiendo en
episodios cada vez más comunes según los
últimos datos de la Organización
meteorológica Mundial Europa es el
continente en que más aumento de la
temperatura se incrementó más del doble
que el resto del planeta en la última
década la Unión Europea emprendió varias
medidas para luchar contra la crisis
climática como la reducción de al menos
el 55% de emisiones contaminantes de
aquí a 2030 pero los científicos alertan
que no es suficiente Asimismo existen
dudas de cómo la actual crisis
energética afectará a los objetivos
climáticos muchos países alargaron la
vida de centrales nucleares tras la
reducción de la dependencia de Rusia o
seguirán quemando carbón ralentizando
una lucha de la que es imposible dar
marcha atrás
y para analizarlo todo Contamos con los
eurodiputados César luena del grupo
socialdemócrata bienvenidos Cesar Qué
tal Hola
y cuando los Monserrat del partido
popular europeo bienvenida qué tal un
placer estar aquí un placer que estéis
los dos Aquí voy a empezar con algunos
datos según el informe sobre la brecha
de emisiones de la ONU se prevé que en
2030 la producción de combustibles
fósiles sea doble al actual Siberia
llegó a los 38 grados hace dos años por
primera vez acelerando el deshielo la
deforestación se ha acelerado en lugares
como el Amazonas 2022 va de camino de
ser de mayor temperatura de la historia
que nos están diciendo estos datos César
que tenemos que incrementar la ambición
que lo que estamos haciendo siendo
importante porque yo no creo que haya
que ser tampoco pesimista en las
decisiones políticas que se toman desde
luego que hay que ser más ambiciosos no
solo en las políticas de reducción de
los gases de efecto invernadero que creo
que estamos siendo punteros sino también
en las políticas de protección de la
naturaleza de restauración de la
naturaleza y de protección de la
biodiversidad estamos ante una crisis
planetaria no solo climática planetaria
una parte es climática la otra parte es
la desaparición de las especies por
tanto que nos dicen esos datos que
tenemos que ser más ambiciosos las
sendas sobre todo la senda de la Unión
Europea es una Senda correcta pero hay
que incrementarla
pues justamente Yo pienso que la Unión
Europea lo está haciendo muy bien lo
estamos haciendo bien desde todas las
instituciones donde estamos liderando en
el mundo la lucha contra el cambio
climático no podemos negar una realidad
y por tanto tenemos que trabajar
conjuntamente para trabajar en medidas
pero cuando hablo de trabajar
conjuntamente ya no solo te la Unión
Europea sino también todo el mundo pero
también con todos los sectores También
tenemos que hacerlo conjuntamente con la
sociedad pero también con los sectores
económicos no podemos perder
competitividad mientras luchamos contra
el cambio climático creo que es
compatible las dos cosas y por tanto yo
me siento orgullosa por parte de un
partido popular europeo que tuvimos a un
comisario español harías cañete que
consiguió el acuerdo de París por tanto
continuemos en esa senda de trabajo pero
ahora mismo estamos en un camino en que
ningún país está ahora mismo es ahora
mismo capaz de limitar el calentamiento
del planeta 1,5 grados
hay que aumentar la ambición Pero
entonces Europa está haciendo lo
suficiente o no Europa está haciendo lo
suficiente Sí porque nosotros nos hemos
marcado un calendario primero a través
de una ley la ley del clima es la
primera ley que existe en el contexto
internacional que dice que vamos a ser
neutrales climáticamente hay que
habernos solamente las emisiones sino
también las Las capturas por así decir
las absorciones en 2050 con pasos
intermedios 30 35 entre 40 y después en
el 50 duros Antes estabas comentando
Bueno no sé si quieres recoger el guante
de César bueno primero el partido
popular europeo y el partido popular
español estamos muy aleja de los
pensamientos negacionistas del cambio
climático podremos discutir de Cómo
llegar a esa no cómo luchar contra el
cambio climático quizás a veces Pues nos
diferencia con el partido socialista
nosotros por ejemplo la Unión Europea lo
he dejado bien claro que la nuclear es
una medida de transición ecológica y
verde y por tanto por ejemplo el partido
popular español apoyamos la energía
nuclear y los socialistas No tanto yo
creo que lo importante es que Europa
lidera la lucha contra el cambio
climático el partido popular no es
negacionista al contrario Pero quizás
las medidas no son las mismas para
llegar al mismo sitio Nosotros también
tenemos muy muy claro que tenemos que
hacer esa transición verde sin dañar a
la economía sin dañar a los bolsillos de
los ciudadanos tenemos que pensar que
ahora mismo en Europa en España estamos
viviendo una crisis que nos dejó el
covid la crisis de la Guerra de Ucrania
la crisis energética la crisis de la
inflación y queremos que este invierno
la gente se pueda calentar en sus casas
por tanto toda esta transición la
tenemos juntamente con la sociedad y por
tanto los objetivos son los que hemos
establecidos pero tenemos que hacerlo
junto a la sociedad Porque queremos que
se calienten en sus casas y que puedan
pagar las facturas de la luz por esto
nosotros apostamos por la renovables
pero también por esa energía de
transición que ha establecido la Unión
Europea como es la nuclear y cómo es el
gas y por tanto necesitamos esas
conexiones de gas desde España hacia el
resto de Europa lo hemos venido
defendiendo siempre no pueden decir los
socialistas lo mismo los españoles
porque cuando llegaron al gobierno el
año 2018 consideraron que el midcat no
era un una infraestructura estratégica y
nosotros la defendimos siempre y ahora
el partido socialista nos ha dado la
razón a nosotros por tanto Estamos de
acuerdo o no en el objetivo pero en las
medidas no nosotros siempre estaremos al
lado de las familias de las empresas Y
por supuesto en proteger nuestro planeta
y nuestro entorno más próximo allá solo
les queda Perdona apoyar la excepción
ibérica de verdad y hablar bien de ella
en Europa y ya con eso seguro que Lo
tendríamos arreglado yo no estoy de
acuerdo no estamos de acuerdo en que
nuclear sean energías de transición no
lo son particularmente en el ámbito de
la nuclear porque es una energía que
genera muchísima inseguridad que hay un
problema después con los residuos y por
tanto el parlamentos legítimo el
parlamento a través de una objeción
rechazó esa objeción y por tanto sigue
adelante el acto delegado de la comisión
europea pero esa es nuestra posición
antes hacía referencia justamente a la
energía nuclear algunos países como
Bélgica y han anunciado que van a
alargar la vida de sus centrales
nucleares de nucleares está permitiendo
también seguir quemando carbón porque
justamente ahora mismo nos encontramos
una crisis energética Pero hay un
peligro de que se pueda dar marcha atrás
en la ambición justamente por la crisis
energética en la que nos encontramos
ahora mismo no yo creo sinceramente o
sea por ejemplo nosotros como País
España estamos completamente
descarbonizados nosotros tenemos
nucleares el partido popular español y
el europeo defendemos pues no la vida de
nucleares tal y como hemos establecido
desde Europa y no hemos establecido con
unas mayorías desde Europa y por tanto
tenemos que ir hacia ese camino igual
como tenemos que apostar por la
renovables igual como tenemos que
apostar por las conexiones de nuestros
no del midcat hacia Europa igual como
tenemos que mantener buenas relaciones
con nuestros socios estratégicos como es
algeria no como ha hecho el gobierno de
España que ha roto esas relaciones y
como nosotros apostamos por un mercado
global europeo de energético sin
diferencias entre Estados para que no
haya competencias no por tanto hay
muchas cosas que podemos hacer por el
buen camino pero siempre pensando en los
ciudadanos europeos Les estamos pidiendo
muchos esfuerzos Por qué Porque ahora no
podemos pedir lo mismo a los ciudadanos
europeos antes de la crisis del covid
antes de la guerra Ucrania antes de la
inflación antes de esa crisis energética
que ahora que lo están sufriendo en sus
propias carnes y es lo único que dice el
partido popular Oiga los objetivos
estamos comentando de acuerdo pero
flexibilicemos en base adaptemos en base
a lo que estamos viviendo en cada uno de
los hogares europeos Pero esto no
significa al contrario significa que
estamos en la lucha contra cambio
climático y que queremos que Europa
continúe liderando en el mundo como
decía César la lucha contra cambio
climático para que se sumen Estados
Unidos China India y todos los países
industrializados del mundo a esa lucha
que estamos haciendo desde Europa y
desde esta casa que es el parlamento
europeo César Bueno yo creo que España
tiene algo que que puede enseñar en este
en este caso primero
hoy en los problemas de hoy la
aplicación de la excepción ibérica junto
con Portugal es un éxito tal es así que
la presidenta de la comisión está
valorando seriamente incorporar esa
excepción ibérica al modelo europeo por
tanto eso es un modelo de gestión que se
puede explorar y en otro caso o en otra
parte estamos con las energías
renovables
creo que hay que ser muy ambicioso como
decía al principio la ambición en la
reducción de los gases de efecto
invernadero es la otra parte de la
moneda también las energías renovables
hemos tenido un mini pleno como se llama
aquí la directiva de renovables la
semana pasada creo que es muy importante
seguir esa senda de defender que la
alternativa de verdad que el modelo para
un futuro no tan lejano son las energías
renovables el caso español cuando se han
quitado los impuestos al sol demuestra
que se puede hacer y por tanto creo que
ese es el camino energía renovables
modelos que sean capaces de limitar la
presencia desmesurada en las facturas
como es lo que se ha llamado excepción
ibérica y
yo entiendo también lo han hecho en
Alemania no solo en algunos países que
decías esta este compromiso está puesta
por la energía nuclear creo que es
errático y quien lo haga tiene que ser
consciente de que debe ser muy puntual
porque porque no podemos mirar al futuro
regresando la mirada a políticas
antiguas
uno de los grandes debates que está que
ha habido en la cop27 es la necesidad de
compensar a las economías menos
desarrolladas por un calentamiento
global del que no son responsables es un
planteamiento adecuado de los totalmente
la Unión Europea ya está ayudando a
través de los programas de cooperación a
muchos países en esta lucha contra el
cambio climático por tanto ese es el
camino es que Europa y ha dicho estamos
liderando esa lucha contra cambio
climático y por tanto llevamos años con
nuestros programas de cooperación desde
la Unión Europea para ayudar a estos
países pero déjame que conteste un
momento a César lunar sobre la excepción
ibérica o sea en la atención ibérica
quien se está beneficiando de verdad son
los franceses con nuestros impuestos a
nosotros al final de cada mes estamos
pagando la excepción ibérica como
españoles pero que nos está comprando
más barato el precio de la luz son los
franceses y quienes están beneficiando
los franceses por eso el partido popular
español El europeo apostamos con una
convergencia real de un mercado único
energético en la unión europeo que todo
el mundo que todos los 27 estados
miembros estemos en el mismo marco
político y jurídico energético porque
así no pasaría que los franceses se
benefician de lo que nosotros pagamos de
la factura de la luz Simplemente no para
dejarlo claro para no dar a confusiones
bueno si puede ver la gente los precios
puede ver la gente los precios puede ver
cómo ha sido las facturas en los países
puede ver también la inflación y ahí
están los datos entonces ante los datos
pero en relación con la pregunta que
hacías sí hay que compensar tanto para
mitigación como adaptación en Glasgow la
cop26 se habló de los famosos
compromisos o diálogos de Glasgow de de
incrementar unas partidas de una manera
muy importante se ha cumplido se está
cumpliendo pues no y tiene que cumplirse
porque una parte del planeta hemos
causado históricamente el cambio
climático y otra parte lo está sufriendo
hay que compensarlo evidentemente pues
Lamentablemente nos hemos quedado sin
tiempo pero muchísimas gracias a César a
ustedes les esperamos en el próximo
programa de Europa hoy Gracias por ver
France 24 en español
[Música]